[Music]
bird box is currently one of Netflix's
most popular films and personally I
think a lot of that can be attributed to
the fact that the monsters within the
movie carry a lot of mystery these
monsters when looked upon and caused the
victim to commit suicide so naturally
there's a lot of speculation rife on the
internet surrounding their appearance
while star Sandra Bullock recently
stated in an interview that they looked
like giant green snake babies
Dirk Rogers who was cast as the creature
and even played it and deleted scenes
stated that this color was simply for
visual effects of course this didn't
really stop the appetite that fans have
in order to find out their actual design
luckily Andy Berke Holt who was a
designer on the film recently posted an
Instagram image and caption with the
original design of the monsters as well
on that image he stated that we had the
unique pleasure of designing creepy
makeup for the film although the scene
ultimately ended up on the cutting room
floor keep in mind that the fatal
visions that each character saw would
likely be different for each person and
this makeup appeared in a cut dream /
nightmare sequence with Sandra Bullock's
character considering her pregnant state
and emotional arc through the movie the
producers felt Sandra's nightmare would
have something to do with the twisted
demonic baby creature attacking her I
sculpted at least three or four
variations on the design before it was
approved which began as a more
aggressive monstery look and was revised
to be a bit more subtle in the end I
also had the pleasure of painting the
finished prosthetics before sending them
to set to be worn and performed by the
one and only Turk Rogers in the end I
actually really liked the movie and
think it was better off not showing the
makeup kudos to the director for
sticking to her guns on that one still a
fun project to be a part of thanks Howie
well I love about this is that the
design definitely ties into Sandra
Bullock's character arc and makes a lot
of sense as to why you would be so
terrifying for
of course the film does work better
without showing the creatures and it's
probably for the best that this never
came to light as the Internet has been
an uproar about how laughable some of
the aspects are obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the monsters and
whether you think they would have worked
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and check out my breakdown of
everything we know so far about glass
which will be linked at the end of this
video this is a channel for people who
are heavy into horror so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]